[Music]
these are monks Oh Oh is that Tiger
belly it says in this me Bobby that's
dead on me dude honestly I love it
that's mom I see mine yours will
probably just shatter in my hand it's so
fragile oh do you see the latest urban
Bobby uh edit no the guy burns me at the
end of it it's the same guy Luke oh yeah
okay ceramics and George you're the
voice of reason I even got my widow's
peak George let me see mine let's even
put pink
[Applause]
[Music]
you always do some of the edges of your
glasses it's very wide Randy yes they do
so cute Thank You grace Lee thank you so
much that's so sweet
oh we don't even ever had eyes here our
fridges from the 1980s how do you know
why do you need ice oh yeah no you core
water ice ice maker the cubes the tray
on the tray dude do we get one of those
you don't even have ice maker trays if
we had ice maker tray would make guys
[ __ ] nut oh my god
I like wait he works from which what he
works tiger belly what's up brother my
boss would probably probably rather I
type this letter on a pretty flower hill
with this spell check but that ain't my
style a very quick story a few months
back our company dream water attended a
show in Anaheim California called Expo
West while talking the talk showing
product and making contacts notice a guy
staring me down but so and so that's who
the booth perhaps but I was in front of
it so I felt the same stare down so
that's who you are
yelled a guy as he came over we dream
team had gone out for drinks the night
before and perhaps had way too many in
this guy wasn't his girl from home last
night so I got into my kung fu stance as
they got closer so that's who you are
you ever hear the tiger belly and I
stood there gazing few since all I hear
these days
are my kids screaming and my wife
yelling you ever heard of Bobby leave
that to me I was funny yes and said and
went on to tell me that you are a big
fan of dream water I told him if you
could get me in an address that I would
reach out to you well he did just do
that Jason Beghe proud listener of your
podcast and huge fan I wouldn't call
this up
well mr. Chuck I think the take force it
don't be a stranger all my contact infos
mark go man's mark mark a poor man's
dead surgery monitor motor connection
we're gonna make that a sponsor all
right happy people a stream water on
table look at this this is from Cora -
thank you garage
oh we got more huh it's good holy geez
oh oh yeah what step wasn't it
Gilbert and George kebab' my ID roof and
porches of hot famous people for
inktober like wha I quit
otherwise G&G would be here too thanks
from terribly out you wonderful I love
every show obviously being kr cuter than
this there's a bias staff yeah
[Music]
Oh did Steve even notice he was in it
this love reasons include you Debbie
Harry steve buscemi and Bobby incline
great keep this forever oh [ __ ] this is
sir except this one is whoa it's wrong
people suck Houston Texas call people
suck this company
I like it oh we got pens - that's pretty
cool all right except for these a letter
regulator Oh - King
hell I'll often live in pink dick thank
you for filling my onesie laughs I'm
sorry Bryce people suck dead lips is
bigger than you now what do you think
that Bryce lips over [ __ ] guys Jason got
some stickers - OH
people suck we're gonna mention them to
you money where's it is my dream water
[ __ ] yeah take that I want to keep one
of these there we go Wazza Wazza Bobbie
Lee we met briefly one time on the
streets of LA I just wanted to thank you
and Carla and Gilbert and mr. pink egg
and everyone involved would talk about I
[ __ ] love the show so thank you for
the laughter tears of how about
information hit me up if you ever want a
tour of my haunt of my heart you can
reach me at his he put his number you
give me his number
all right oh look at this alright look
at these look at these are Bobby weights
we're really good wow that's really good
let me get a t-shirt of that I feel
really good there's one of Jesus is this
just a letter
what is he just put it on top of this or
is that the gift oh yeah he just put it
on my book uh is this what covers that's
a good
I can't wear this but you will oh my god
which is like pins have to be [ __ ] oh
yeah by the cast this is on big dude
that's type of it all wait wait who is
that is that
works for the show oh my god
Battle of the bastards written by David
Benioff and DB Weiss wait someone from
this show just write ups because that
looks like a like a professional
envelope this is someone from production
is no hold on there must be a letter
here there it is autograph 101 key
so there's george RR martin signed it
the producers paper where is it it tells
you the number take the number take the
number in the back okay hang on one
second Jon Snow Jon Snow or number four
get Harrington right there don't add
don't open that that's valuable
I don't like a frame situation it says
it's customs declaration so it's not
from here is it real it's real those are
real signatures cuz look at the ink it's
not all black and white Jaime Lannister
Ramsay Emilia Clarke sign is sophie
turner lena headey woodland Christie
thank you that's amazing I'm gonna take
a picture of it no no don't do it don't
post until you know no they know we got
this gift and I want to know how many
dozen are of those I would like to know
yeah if it's like a limited
England is also in every corner does not
call Oh what what is that
oh no what is it it's a it's an actual
is it real it's real no no hey dad look
no no real speakers speakers oh it works
hi fire-bellied I wanted to sit a little
something special for your new house
it's a touch of babes we called the king
so the king for the slub king thank you
very much Audio King this one is here is
from Shaolin let's se what's that
Lexington South Carolina yeah and this
is right here yes I love it when you
call me big eNOS what do we got here we
got this is from love covers LLC from
Phoenix Arizona
right here tough covers what is it Oh
for your comma Oh for your ankles or
your for your wrists you got a gift
koala for when you're working on the
factory so your uh your cuffs don't get
caught in the machinery is that what it
is it looks like it from the photo thank
you for that stunt dream water but close
it's very close almost they know
honestly thank you no honestly and thank
you for the fell covers I don't know be
real hello yeah why are you laughing Oh
Burt I don't know why you're gonna know
I apologize yeah I apologize to the
ground and now this these are deceiving
cuz they're big because they're big but
they're empty big and empty like Harvey
Weinstein yes true find a heart I call
these Barbies hey Harvey trying too hard
that's not documentary that I bought but
then I numbers Hey
yes thank you
err yeah no this is one of these things
yes what is it
open it yes right
Oh ice cube trays is what it's a cool
ice cube tray we didn't have ice for
Bert oh yeah thank you for the ice cube
trays you got one here
but ice cube cheese by who this is from
Ola let's what does Papa me amigos
once one ice cube maker for the lead
residents one for brown skin for skin
and one for PD for the GW enjoy nice
from early FB be Val IG Murphy it's from
him again
this guy's really stepping it up this
Kevlar thing if you were in town
robot sucker day well your dick sucked
this is what I hear it just won't burn
me again I'm gonna call the cops
this one's from dream Products LLC Oh
oh my god
really this one is from hi tiger belly
love you babies x you'll sleep my child
from Anthony carvaka no callers Vil some
Collegeville Pennsylvania and this is
the dream water trouble bundle kit mmm
and this dude right here this dude right
here is a winner event whoever this
person is is a winner for life and you
know what you just got let me just see
something right now you just got blessed
by Slough game and I'm gonna tight right
now
you're gonna get [ __ ] so much because I
command it oh my god Wow no one thinks
any of this okay I got the dream powder
which I love can you pet it with this
what this is [ __ ] now that was this
evening that was a trick that was a
right but we got the water here to these
news berry
oh my god that bless you we'll take care
of most of [ __ ] baby tonight to
kalila Gilbert and George I understand
already Eric Andreea from Eric and
Andrea from Los Angeles California
okay first of all guys great job
taping this this is ridiculous yes
defeat Barry's
Oh what is this Eric Andre oh okay I
shall read mr. Bobby no it's just Frost
three this is the one special moment we
have guys so Bobby was excluded yeah he
got mad rush order um it's a picture of
a family that's very cute too Bobby
oh she does say - Bobby - Bobby kalila
Gilbert and George from their
rush-ordered team Bobby
kalila Gilbert and George we're huge
Tiger belly fans over here and just
wanted to send you a quick note to let
you know how much we appreciate all the
work that you guys put into the podcast
appreciate we listen to it's on a
podcast in our office the tiger bellies
season easily our go-to please keep
doing what you're doing will be waiting
eagerly for the next episode to come out
like we do every week sincerely the rush
order team yes when Sookie the dum-dum
making his or her sorry trying to be a
gender-neutral here when it's Toki the
dumb dumb making his next appearance
very cute and that's the rush order team
there's a picture oh what'd we get what
do we get okay we receive some rush
order shirts oh they're so cute
ladies freshwater it's a restaurant
right oh it says yes we'll find out I
think it's like a snap oh it's an app
it's an app Oh
oh so it's like okay brush away so we
got more of each thank you so much
sponsorship shorter you guys I know
you're a sneaky bastard
thank you so much I love white shirts
because my sweaty armpits don't stain
them so yay I will wear it to the gym
today my Angela Johnson hmm no stickers
this is from Chris M from Denver
Colorado
my fingers though I can get one of those
wouldn't your mo probably or Whitney
your face if she's available mo oh my
god even better
George is losing two stickers what else
brace yeah number one death okay father
figure other Mandela stuff
yeah but then call it the bunk
everything was exciting was exciting to
hear ones for breeze how do you spell it
heavy ball see I know is for febr dze
why just say something why would you
think it was spelled that way because
breeze is in Chris me right humans you
look for things that are fantastical
when there's a perfectly logical
explanation of why were just asked a
question and I answered it aboard are
you with your [ __ ] life that you have
to build what is a breeze with one EE
yeah it's like come on dude just because
you know breeze is spelled with two E's
this guy you picking your nose while
you're talking now who's the bully now
well here's another one that [ __ ] me
up is uh you know Jif peanut butter yeah
I always thought was jiffy know I always
knew it's Jeff you know why cuz he's a
fat boy yeah yeah there might be it
maybe you're coming up with shitty
examples no I literally thought well
that's [ __ ]
you're a bully tonight man you what you
know I'm angry about this what because I
was sleeping it was 3:00 a.m.
screaming I have something to say and I
thought like something bad yeah the
[ __ ] car had crashed in a garage he
ran into a neighbor or something like
that
oh he wakes me up and he's like I gotta
tell you
and he's like honey some Febreze I was
living in an alternate reality house is
this happening right I'm gonna wake up
[ __ ] strange like place where Bobby's
not screaming asking me to submit the
spell Febreze and that's why I have I
have beef with this whole Mandela effect
because that's how this fool woke me up
mmm so say you're [ __ ] sorry and then
I will debunk any of your [ __ ]
mashing this question yes c-3po is he
all gold yes no silver at one point
maybe one of his legs of silver really
yeah that's a Mandela effect yeah it's
not just I just didn't know your I just
got stabbed by snake
oh it's for Steve it says hey Steve I
really enjoy watching you because it
reminds me of my older brother okay I'm
taking the beanie yeah that's the rudest
thing I've ever seen in my [ __ ] life
Charlie Charlie knew Charlie made a
mistake thanks for the beanie charlie
man thanks man really charlie man gave
it to me Bobby I'm Cherokee oh thanks
charlie
that's what is this this is a five year
supply glaze is a great one we should
hang it the next one is this it's a
brown box no we open it up and it says
flamin what are the ice ball trays yeah
and this is a little no so I'm gonna
read the note targa really Steve
Savannah Georgia yes Steve so then just
told me one was for me that you know
know somebody message me that they got
an ice ball the shoe trees for all this
one was packed it's oddly it's big it
says caution heavy it's not that heavy
and it's already kind of open dad guys
today
it really doesn't after I came into the
office I being a very big boss and
inside is a t-shirt that says Tiger
belly oh this is cool
damn look at a friend tiger bill it's a
painting there's a there's smaller stuff
in the front body and then this is a
slept King this is cool it's someone
drew on it
flip interesting you love it and it's
just Tiger belly somebody drew on this
that's dope this is bugs thank you he
sent us back on a mug I doesn't again it
says celeb can t-shirt ideas inside
these shirts were going to Goodwill
anyway they're clean thanks Seth thanks
Seth oh my God look at this he made I
need a booklet booklet oh my god these
are all ID this is a beautiful mind look
at this give this away somebody help me
that can you somebody help me get out of
the way thank you thank you getting up
you [ __ ] [ __ ] sorry
alright so on these are this is a
[ __ ] crazy person but this is a crazy
person I love it though thanks Seth it's
very special how do you explain the
enclosed two mugs I ordered two one
broke I received two replacement love's
than my actual replacement mugs i order
to pass these along to other sleepers
please okay so do you got an extra yeah
what a nice day nine-time all the
sketches ideas inspired by the episodes
I am artist at heart we all are the
shirts were headed to Goodwill anyway
and they're clean a more useful
something I read a tweet where Bobby
send me he doesn't know Korean that
didn't stop me and uh Tiger Bell okay
I'm like oh my god yeah kalila in my
eyes you're both bless beings of light
we all are
so not just you and me everyone you two
created a universe where people can be
themselves including yourself sleeper
says thank you sleepers thank you sleep
now that you're the doll best pretty
good vagina
you know what the height difference is
actually perfect yeah I love my eyes on
this it's like not like a model or
something I like it when they're in
boxes did you never know oh you can also
eat it as just a powder it's delicious
hot water but then let do me a favor
just eat it as a powder it's delicious
right all right now I wasn't making fun
of that but yeah as a kid there was a
soy milk that I just eat the powder of
so I can't really
cheese last summer came back and yeah
you're like that to price alright open
there and this one's from Eric rebels
refinery Canada st. your Canada it's a
refinery it's an ID and one of these are
on ie D and explodes on their bus so sad
oh yeah this one right here is got some
cards here it says hey guys oh yeah hope
all is well my name is Eric Fallon I'm a
huge fan of pot guys actually only
listened to two podcast Tiger Valley and
how I built this with guys you can file
under who gives a [ __ ] I happen to own a
company called rebels refinery premium
natural skin care for humans we
currently sell at every target location
I was just curious about sponsoring your
podcast I know it might seem weird but I
please check out our stuff please see
people seem to be obsessed with our lip
balms this way this is I've seen it oh
here they are I think this is a freebie
what do you guys think just get a quick
get a quicker we'll look into it
dirty boy bamboo face in a body way yeah
these are these are for us to try for us
to try but can I have it for me as long
as you soulless [ __ ] whoa goddamnit
I'm tired of your selfishness
ooh - yeah this is scarlet bomb pack
babe look look at this lip balm great
packaging oh wow man I want to try the
pineapple one well thank you buddy
look at it we'll look at it we love it
thank you
well let me try the trace but yeah this
one right here look at this right here
oh not cast iron to wash the glaze in
hot water after cook wiped clean coat
with a thin layer of oil never you have
to turn it flip will outlive any of us
if treated well she look she's gonna
destroy we're not good we're not giving
any agenda that's ours we're not giving
it to Jenna you know like there's more
than just one meal to make ahead all
right fine I opened that everything uh
here's
three more Danny Danny parks Dundee
Oregon oh [ __ ] water powder again I'm in
the whole world already this is a look
at this what is it tomato all of us
paste sort of organic seed that's for
George I know it was this from Connor
no Mandy tiger Billy crew hi guys here's
your dream water Bobby enjoy I'm a big
fan come to Portland [ __ ]
Mandy sweets for a white one Jean yeah
that's me
Thank You Mandy thank you that's really
nice
Daniel cool this one right here Jessie
Ramona we've had stuff I'm just at the
forum we have yeah I like Jessie we oh
oh what's that one yeah
oh that guy yeah Jesse Ramone on this
Hey look out dope it's so legit thank
you dude Jesse Ramone do be careful
didn't put this in a nice place
that's art Thank You Jesse thanks for
your art - this is from Gino Batista and
he made us wow this is close no way Oh
your belly don't bleach it spray paint
no it's spray painter so that's dope
though so cute so cute thank you dude
this is great
Gina Baptista this is from Wow Sleeping
Beauty is the Beatles oh yeah dear Bobby
koala
I'm a huge fan of the show and Bobby I
know you have been down lately so I'm up
some Beatles will show you loads of love
Linda Lee Thank You Linda so nice this
is the I treasure these who the Beatles
you what [ __ ] face are you sober
[ __ ] face in my life hey [ __ ] face what
do we do that time hey [ __ ] hold the
sponsors there's a lotta way up that's
one I honestly don't recall saying [ __ ]
face ever oh oh my god all right age
gated but worth it age gated but worth
it let's H get it man
when you can't put ads on your video cuz
it's for older people it's good sure so
what's the area was there uh I'd say I
go over to read I'll try
[Music]
although Tiger bellied it is with great
respect and gratitude that I'm sending
this gift to the slop King Bobby Lee Wow
I saw this and knew that I must get this
for the fearless leader he doesn't make
it I did not want to wait until November
molestation day to send it remember that
Iran is not hot enough
however it doesn't mean that the rest of
the rest of you are forgotten
I'm just cheap I wanted to thank
everyone for the hours and hours of
entertainment I don't remember when I
discovered Tiger belly but what I did I
just know the water tasted sweeter
colors were more vivid and my erections
were mortar turgut and longer-lasting
mmm I'm gonna read this letter and
that's a really good I'm gonna read this
letter on I love the dynamic between
Bobby and kalila I have never seen a
better example what really real
relationships are like I think that we
are looking for a person understand what
our worst is still love the villain
bilbo baggins pink dick george and the
rest of one of the best if not the best
pop guess ever produced and guitar very
much are far apart I won't look at
Pringles over the same tea hellos to do
either letter I generally don't look
write letters and there's no skips [ __ ]
yeah you know that everyone yeah
sticker and it says he walks hello I'm a
longtime fan since watching MADtv as a
child I don't ever waste time but I just
want to say in my opinion Bobby's a most
endearing comedy actor I've ever seen
since John Candy Gene Wilder or red
skeleton I'm always compared to those
bad guys he's read this letter today I
really get the impression that he cares
whether he is lighting lightening
anyone's heart or comes to real
appreciate it I was at thought he is
ever composted you may find it funny but
okay Josh you're the guy that records
like people having the cake without you
happy birthdays oh my god these are my
favorite oh my god no water required I
like to put it in my Red Bull do have a
counter in fact oh that's nice yeah no I
put it in here too is it does a counter
effect you know there right Jason so I
do that as I do this and does a counter
effect so sake bringing water oh my god
with them the tab touching heart pump Oh
oh my god would I do wrong why dream
water we're using your bag jobs to clean
it up thank you to the bag
[Music]
oh these are costumes
[Laughter]
what is that Worthen tiger it's a tiger
we even know
I'll read the note
sweetie
I hate to tell you this yeah oh wait
this is yours okay I was gonna say one
says the crown weighs heavy on the
king's head plus capes are cool I feel
like you should wear that today from
Halloween I'm wearing this no okay and
the other one is Gilbert's this is for
you my friend as a butt flap so you can
continue your signature shenanigans hey
Gilbert
give me some more yeah these are more
costume better costume summers gonna
wear some costumes here
[Music]
there's no no no what is it
Polly Reve south to come away to come
this is a defend the future where does
trick-or-treating with the kids it's a
penis thank you clothing company what
you wear all this Oh Polly Reve
yeah hold up the back so I can see it
and you'd like it it's cool it's just
Polly it's oversized Thank You Polly I
hate that [ __ ] - Tiger belly
I stopped sending candy I don't want you
to get diabetes jewelry
[Music]
beany any donkey Oh big side of your
podcast that you might like this keep
doing what you're doing
yes Yong Yong Yong GI yo-yo Nisha young
Yoshio and nanny
Eddie amenadiel Yoshio thank you so much
I'm gonna be wearing this [ __ ] all time
I like this see this is cool I'm safe a
[ __ ] King the font everything's cool
about this thing man
open it from kms what is it other
buttons
oh yeah buttons
Oh like hangar belly butter belly buns
this was this kringles sponges rubber
bands latex gloves dude this is amazing
this is amazing each button each was as
a tiger belly thing sweats yeah Toki the
dum-dum this is amazing me that who made
it but times are hard and that post and
that postage money could go a long way
McDonald's keep up the good work and
stay slip from kyon K on let me know if
you would like me to send more these are
amazing be the dumb dumb George pink
dick what's this we got two more so
here's probably music huh prime video Oh
you know but I have a middle-aged woman
sweet feet money what money money money
we have money he send us money
three dollars it's on the fall
what's on it something so here he's
worried about your the sticker TV show
money it's a crown sticker very cute
somebody guess mangoes let me finish
this real quick cuz it's just press play
okay
[Music]
let it's for you rockin all of course
let the good times roll
here mr. Kimmel I wish you a very happy
birthday always wear a condom even on
your birthday AIDS is everywhere I don't
know you're getting gifts like Queen and
whoever she deems worthy of sharing in
their bounty wait that was the Bengals
yeah do we have one more one more letter
this is the last thing here I think this
is the one I'm so New Jersey really it
seems like it's our Roxie thing but I
don't know yeah oh my god somebody drew
this this is amazing
okay this is art you look like lava you
fill the void I've heard DVDs they keep
doing what you're doing let me know if
you want any shirt designs I'll be happy
to create some I am so 77 I am so this
is amazing we got to keep all this [ __ ]
and treasurer put this in we have a
special place we do for gifts yeah
there you go that's great George let's
just write this out all right well Bobby
wanted it from a podcaster oh I got more
yeah more seeds seed it's the same yeah
tomato seeds last yeah it's jumbled pink
banana winter squash okay nice no thank
you
what's the use of a knife that's not
readily available what's gonna be Sunday
just only us you want to go I'll be fun
who knows maybe super male 12 the TV
version from Smallville thank you one of
these couple of brown paper
oh [ __ ] what is this like a pole teeth
no this is babes a jewel sided jewel oh
yeah yeah is that from I don't know but
this person saved my life oh this is it
kind of like the jewel yeah
love to show her who you're talkin about
juin you wanted to quit smoking I own an
online vape shop I wanted to help you
out this is fix start a kick along with
a variety pack it helped has helped my
friend mom working after 30 years
hopefully you can do is with them long
live the celeb king